look at that that's a beautiful photo do
you recognize this person yeah that's me
yeah who's the other person yeah yeah
wife yep damn
have you gotten used to that yet yeah I
like I like saying it yeah wife it's so
much easier than fiance when better than
girlfriend yeah it's just like I wanted
to say it before beforehand like I found
myself saying it even before we were
married I say wife when I have a partner
um I just like refer it's either queen
or wife okay yeah and it feels good now
it's nothing I got uh maybe that's why
yeah I have no one so I don't say
anything
oh but then I scare them away no no not
at all probably shouldn't be it's other
things that scare them away oh okay
actually nothing nothing I do is scary
yeah that's a little bit weird no it's
true though I I uh nothing I do is is
that freaky if anything I'm I'm cursed
with being a good partner
I'm just too damn good I'm too generous
I'm too generous uh yeah well look at
that yeah it's you guys is that the
first perfect perfect day the best yeah
you say that it was the best day of your
life it's actually true yeah like
honestly like the whole day I I've never
felt like that happy
and just like
elated content everything it was just
everything was [__] perfect that's
wonderful yeah good for you it was so
great
well we're gonna do like a whole recap
next week Kelsey and I on our respective
podcasts yeah so I'm you know
I'm not gonna get into it too heavily
today sure but I can tell you it was
great it was great what food was served
what was the main dish we had uh it was
family style and uh what I don't know
why that's I I don't know why that's
funny it's just a funny phrase why it's
because it just I I think of
have you ever seen Idiocracy no you
gotta watch idiots okay it's a great
movie but it's about how the world turns
into idiots and there's this one scene
where
these idiots
are talking about the main guy's love
interest in the he goes hey you mind if
we go family style on her and it's just
it's gross but every time I hear that
I'm like
so anyway it was family you know I kind
of pictured when you laughed what I kind
of pictured you picturing like you know
like the waiter brings over like a
family of chickens
you know what I mean like it's family
style it's like the mom chicken
like baby chickens and you gotta kill
them or something oh yeah like these
were all part of the same yeah they're
all like rotisserie but they're like
it's like a family yeah you know that
would be so cruel to have at your
wedding yeah yeah so [__] up it would
be yeah did you serve uh dead animals
salmon yeah and chicken okay and uh and
some tagliatelle I believe yeah truffle
pasta yes
food was really good that place is
incredible it's the it's the um the
venue is the Sands Hotel in uh Palm
Desert and that restaurant in there is
called the pink Cabana and they just
like are fantastic the tasting like you
know we did a tasting like two months
before the wedding where we went to Palm
Springs and and ate there yeah so much
fun
Palm Desert is great yeah my family used
to uh have a timeshare out there oh yeah
yeah super oh yeah that's where we go
every year with Kelsey's family like the
what's uh probably like maybe uh censor
that but yes
yeah okay well then I won't continue
with the description there's nothing
exactly the lobby that has the the yeah
yeah wow that's great yeah like the yeah
yeah that's where we used to do it yeah
so Kelsey's grandma and grandpa had a
had a time share there and then they've
since passed but they we still like they
still have it in the family so yeah
every year we go there for a week
um and then I actually used to you know
what's [__] crazy what uh maybe I
should say this for next week but [__]
it I used to I used to also so the
reason why we chose this is because you
know this place is really important to
her because she's been going there ever
since she was a child with her family
every year right and then I also used to
go there my grandparents it's like a big
place for calgarians and like people in
Alberta to come during the winter like
if they have a second place it's usually
in like Palm Springs yeah
um so my my grandparents also had like a
small condo there and in the same resort
near it like oh wow like five to ten
minutes away so I would go there as a
kid and then my Grandma had a stroke
when I was like eight or no younger than
that we couldn't go anymore because she
wasn't like well enough
so and then we've been going every year
with our best friends for Coachella
right right and so like you know just
generally it's like a place that
represents like love and family to us
yeah your paths are very well may have
crossed too yeah exactly maybe but this
is the craziest part
so my Grandpa gave a speech
um at the wedding and this is the one
that I used to you know come to Palm
Desert with and he hasn't been back
since
since my Grandma had a stroke way way
back wow
um so it's been like you know 50 or it's
been like 20 years or something
and so Kelsey and I were like looking
around for venues and nothing like felt
quite right and then we went here after
our other friend's wedding and we were
like wow this place is amazing and we
asked if they did weddings and they were
so accommodating everything was so
[__] perfect it was just like the
perfect place it just felt right you
know yeah and my grandpa
in his speech at his wedding he was like
he was like I
you know I'm Cody's Grandpa if you don't
know like we used to come here as a
child or when Cody was a kid but way
before that when me and his grandma came
here for the very first time we drove
down from Calgary
all the way down from Calgary geez and
you know we had driven for like a couple
days and we were finally in Palm Desert
but I had no idea where to stay where to
go what to do and I needed some rest and
so we pulled off on the side of the road
at a at a motel
and we stayed there and it was this
place no [__] yeah wow and all of us
were like holy [__]
it's insane I know right yeah their very
first time in the desert this place was
around there's nothing around it it was
the only hotel for like miles now it's
all developed and stuff around there but
it was like the only hotel for miles and
it was that place that's really special
I know all of us were sitting there like
floored like people just didn't even
think it was true they were like how
could that what are the odds yeah damn
what's it like to have a living
grandparent
it's pretty it's pretty it's pretty cool
yeah I got none yeah I got none anymore
yeah I still have still have two which
ones my both the dads
two grandpas two grandpas cool the other
one it's not well enough he couldn't
make it um that's a bummer up in Canada
yeah yeah
uh 90 95 or something wow yeah longevity
for 90 now I think he's 90. one of my
favorite memories about uh Palm Desert
is
did you ever you ever notice those signs
that say watch for drifting sand
no there are because there can be like
wind storms that can kick up sand and
along the road along the highway it'll
say watch for drifting sand and when we
were vacationing there I remember one
time my dad was like hey boys you see
that sign it was like dusk and it was
pretty windy and he's like you see that
sign watch for drifting sand and we're
like yeah and he goes drifting sand was
a serial killer that they that they
never found and it scared the [__] out
of us because that's that's a [__]
freaky ass name drifting sand you know
and um yeah watch for drifting sand and
oh man yeah that was the second part of
my grandpa's speech yeah drifting saying
yeah you know they never caught that
serial killer either
anyways
that's cool